notre envoyé spécial à moscou c'est
julie dong l'ofs écouter la russie dans
ses médias et systématiquement présentée
comme et bien l'agressé et non
l'agresseur et les images qui filtrent
sur ces médias se concentrent
systématiquement sur la population du
donbass et sur la protection de cette
population en revanche lorsqu'on parle à
la jeune génération russe celle qui a
accès aux informations et bien via leur
vpn qui permet de débloquer cette
censure qui s'installe en russie qui a
accès à une information est bien qui
vient notamment d'autres d'autres pays
ou qui vient d'ukraine et bien eux sont
extrêmement inquiets sur leur pays pour
leur pays je parlais hier à une jeune
femme dans un restaurant qui était
serveuse dans un restaurant elle était
désespérée elle me disait en larmes mais
je ne sais plus quoi faire j'ai honte
pour mon pays s'il vous plaît dites à
vos téléspectateurs que et bien la
russie se dit euh là que les russes ne
sont pas poutine que nous ne sommes pas
d'accord avec cette guerre savez ici les
peu de personnes qui tentent de
manifester leur opposition à cette
guerre peuvent se faire arrêter hier
nous étions dans une manifestation dans
le centre ville de moscou à l'appel de
l'opposant russe alexeï navalni et la
présence policière était extrêmement
importante il y avait la police
anti-émeute absolument partout dans la
ville tout était bouclé on a pu voir des
dizaines de jeunes qui se tenait
silencieux face à ces policiers c'est
leur manière de manifester ils savent
très bien que s'ils brandissent un
slogan par exemple les seuls font
arrêter immédiatement c'est le cas de
plus de 7000 personnes depuis le début
de cette guerre donc ceux qui s'opposent
à cette guerre aujourd'hui et bien
tentent de manifester comme ils peuvent
via des hashtags sur les réseaux sociaux
via des pancartes affichées sur des murs
via des graffitis via une fleur devant
l'ambassade d'ukraine mais c'est très
compliqué pour eux de s'exprimer est ce
que me disaient d'autres jeunes c'est
qu'ils cherchaient un moyen à présent de
quitter le pays